Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host, Ricardo Loops. And today I'm
joined by Doctor Antoine Marie. He is a postdoctoral
researcher at the Department of Political Science at a
University in Denmark. Uh We've already had an interview
on the show. I'm leaving a link to it
in the description box of this one where we
talked basically about misinformation, conspiracy theories and some other
topics. And today we're going to expand a little
bit on that and also talk about a few
more topics like for example, how people evaluate political
decisions, the sharing of fake news on social media,
gender biases in hiring processes, the repression of free
speech, political activism. And basically, as we go through
those topics, we're going to focus mostly on the
biases that arise from people having strong moral convictions
and the consequences of those moral convictions. So, Antoine,
welcome back to the show. It's always a pleasure
to everyone.
Thanks a lot, Ricardo and uh thanks a lot
for having me again.
So starting with how people evaluate political decisions. I
mean, is it that they care more about the
concrete impact that certain political decisions have on society
or do they care more about the values and
perhaps symbols that drive those same political decisions?
Mm. So it's a big topic. I imagine you're
referring to uh pre print that I have with
the co-author uh I got had and brand, brand
Freeland who was my ph advisor, it provisionally called
intentions and efficiency and policy variations. But I would
like to rename maybe something like people don't care
too much about policy efficiency and they value a
lot, the the intentions are driving them. And so
basically what we're doing in that, in that pretty
simple um setup is that we present participants with
like the new little vignette that present, you know,
the, the sort of like the decision making process
of a politician or a CEO who's willing to
implement a new policy for uh for instance, I
don't know, do you know co2 emissions and you
know, protect the environment or whatnot? We provide information
about the level of efficiency or impact that the
policy has its financial cost? Is it gonna cause,
you know, the state or the or the company
to lose vast amounts of money or to save
vast amounts of money and we manipulate whether the
decision maker is altruistic motivated. You know, I, I
want to do that because I want to help
the issue I want to protect the environment versus
um I really don't care about the environment. All
I'm interested in is to improve the image of
our company or, you know, uh increase chances that
we get re elected at the next election or
whatnot. And so, so it's, it's a pretty simple
setup, you know, it does, it doesn't necessarily max
out in terms of like external validity, but it
allows us to pretty carefully manipulate factors that are
seemingly of interest in how people, you know, ordinary
people form attitudes uh about whether a political, political
decision is good or bad, you know, laudable or
not, et cetera. And what we tend to find
is that even when, even when the policy is,
is described as having, you know, absolutely anecdotal positive
impact, like less than 1% efficiency, decreasing CO2 emissions.
And when it described as being, you know, costing
a huge fortune to the company or to the
state, in other words, when the policy is described
as being vastly inefficient, just the fact that we
described the policy as being otherwise altruistically motivated, you
know, in the way it's being implemented by the
minister or, or the CEO leads most participants to
rate the policy as being more commendable or to
or to support it more than an alternative policy
that is described as being super, super efficient, uh
as you know, allowing the organization to save vast
amounts of money. But that is described as being
implemented for reasons that have to do with the
pursuit of, you know, a good image being re-elected
or whatnot. And so we think that's a little
of concern because, you know, in uh modern societies,
many of the motivations that private actors, but also
potentially public actors have on the market in society
is to um uh make profits, is to, you
know, give themselves a good image is to potentially
uh you know, find technological solutions that will allow
them to become richer. And so if people punish
or do not support um policy programs uh policy
uh initiatives, they are motivated by, you know, the
willingness to uh make money to become richer, to
have a successful company, even when they're actually immensely
beneficial for society, even when they massively, you know,
help at solving a given problem that, you know,
humanity is facing, that's clearly problematic. And so, well,
we're just finding that in that in, in, in
those in those set of studies that people don't
seem to be very consequentialist or very pragmatic in
the way that they rate policy decisions. They seem
to care a lot about the intentions that drive
the poli political policies and they seem to disregard
a lot um the the policy impact. Now I
should specify that the way we describe the policy
impact is not completely neutral, we provide um uh
information about the efficiency in numerical format. We don't
provide graphs that is not in the current version
of the experiments. So the defense of that choice
is to say, well, you know, very often information
about political policies impact is provided in numerical format,
in journals, in newspapers, etcetera. So it's fairly ecologically
valid. But at the same time, you could say,
well, yeah, but no surprise that people are not
really reacting too much to, you know, uh numerical
descriptions of, of imbalances in policy efficiency. Because the
the mind is not particularly equipped to, you know,
give a lot of like intuitive meaning to figures,
to big figures to represent all those of magnitude
clearly et Zara. And of course, I would of
course agree with that. And that's also one of
the arguments in the paper, we essentially say that
people tend to deviate from the principles of pragmatism
when assessing uh the political policy that we expose
them to and that we present them to because
essentially the mind is mostly shaped by natural selection
to react to signals about, you know, the value
as a cooperator of potential uh social actors. Be
it the CEO be it the minister so that
people will spontaneously attend to, they will care whether
or not this or that politician seems to be
a good cooperator and they will take into account
the intentions that animates them in implementing the policy
a lot. But as for the the the more
abstract, the more delayed, the more macro you know,
level uh impact of the policy, that's not something
that the mind in two D process is very
well unfort unfortunately, and that we think, you know,
the the two mechanisms combined we think are leading
people to, to become so uh so insensitive to,
to the principles of, of pragmatic. Yeah.
A a and also I'm not completely sure if
this is relevant to the particular context of this
study and what we're you were trying to understand
there. But I, isn't it also the case that
for many, if not most political decisions, uh people
many times do not really have access to very
accurate data or perhaps sometimes it's also very hard
to predict the precise impact that specific policies will
have on society.
No, of course, I mean, 100% agreement. Uh That's
obviously the case. Um YOU know, a fact like
is that politician good or bad as a person,
is there more character, you know, two or three
or three in the, in the perspective of cooperating
with them? That's almost like a fact, something that
you can assess, you know, by direct observation, by
interacting with people or by seeing how they talk,
by seeing how their, you know, claims over time
are consistent with each other, whether they do what
they say and they say what they do or
what not. So that seems relatively easy to assess
but policy efficiency, not so right. It's like very
high level facts. It's often very much delayed in
time. You know, you will only know if um
a political program, you know, meant to fight. Uh
I don't know poverty in Africa or meant to
reduce inequalities or to uh reduce unemployment or whatnot.
You will only know if it will bear its
fruits in the, in the midterm future, even in
the long term future, it interacts like a zillion
number of variables in the national economy and in
the global economy that you have no control over,
it's extremely hard to run randomized control trials on
economic outcomes or, you know, public policies, everything interacts
with, with a bit of everything. Of course, economists
are skilled at kind of like, you know, maximizing
uh the possibility of like answering scientifically to those
questions and assessing policy impact. But it's always very
difficult for everyone, including for them. And it's obviously
not surprising that the lay citizen, you know, the
man in the street, the woman in the street
is not well equipped to anticipate um you know,
what will be the, the the macros social impact
of a policy, I mean to, to, to infer
to, to induce any sort of like conclusion about
whether a policy works or doesn't work. You have
to, you would have to ideally have access to
facts and outcomes that are distributed on the on
the territory, which is of course impossible to do
individually. Uh Most people are not professional scientists, uh
social scientists, sociologists, economists. Um AND, and even assuming
that people have access to relatively reliable policy information,
which is already extremely hard to do, you know,
requires representative samples, it requires the econometric method, etcetera,
etcetera. Even assuming that people have that information very
often that information that rigors, uh you know, opinion
that they may come up with about whether a
given program works or, or or doesn't work at,
you know, advancing a given political issue. People will
often not have the motivation to act on the,
on the, on the basis of that. So for
instance, I might know that it's, you know, bad
nowadays to eat meat and to take the plane.
And I might know very well reflectively that I'm
supposed to stop eating meat or at least beef
and take the plane less. Well, it's pretty hard
from a mot visional perspective to be completely compelled
to act in accordance with those principles. I try,
I try my best but very often, you know,
I'm experiencing a sort of like weakness of will
and I will fail to meet in practice those
sort of like more standards that I claim to
have and that I claim to follow.
Mhm. Uh Let me just ask you one more
question before we move on to another topic about
this. And this is perhaps something that I will
also ask you when it comes to other topics
we're going to explore here today. But when it
comes to this particular study, I mean, do you
expect this to apply to basically everyone, regardless of
their, for example, political ideology or partisanship or I
mean, is there any way, by which perhaps there
are some differences between, for example, left and right
liberals and conservatives or not?
Um, IT'S a, it's a big question. I wouldn't
claim to be able to answer this one. So
I'm a political psychologist but I don't really claim
to be a specialist of like, uh, you know,
subgroup differences or, or more, more differences across, um,
uh, yeah, across differences of partisanship or, or more
sensitivity. I would say that a tendency to overvalue
intentions with respect to causes that you care about,
you know, to, to want to positively reward or,
or, or thank, you know, politicians or social actors
who are helping an issue versus wanting to punish
those who are selfish or who disregard the cause
that you care about that will tend to be
universal, I think because it's very likely to be
part of our sort of like universal, you know,
social cognition package. It's like cognitive skills that you
need to engage all the time every day and
that you would have had to engage, you know,
ancestrally regularly over the millennials to gauge the trustworthiness
of potential co-operation partners. So this you should expect
will be so much universal. Now, at the same
time, of course, there are differences are, you know,
relevant morally. And so it's possible that people who
are a bit like, you know, who have a
bit of a effective altruist sensitivity or who are
maybe a bit more libertarian or maybe a bit
more on the autistic spectrum or whatnot. It's possible
that people who have those personality characteristics who are
a little less, you know, um, elsewhere than in
the cognitive average of the population. It's possible that
those people may on average spontaneously or being or,
or maybe educated to value policy impact a bit
more than the good principles and the intentions that
drive them, that they may be a bit more
psychologically compatible with the principles of utilitarianism and pragmatism.
Uh I think there's some evidence doing that, but
I don't claim to be a, I don't claim
to be a specialist of that. And um and
yeah, and as regards the policy efficiency, I think,
yeah, most people will have difficulty, you know, representing
uh orders of magnitudes and, and, and impacts and
to gauge policy efficiency based on figures. But of
course, here again, there's a bit of margin of
leeway. If you, you know, learn for many years
that if you work for many years at the
Ministry of the Economy or whatnot, you learn to
many people and to handle figures and to represent
what they mean a bit more, you have more
of a sense of like, you know what 10
million represents with respect to as compared to 1
billion. And you are be able to get a
sense of like what is the budget of the
state? What is the budget of the company and
that puts you in a better position to reason
about figures. I think, I think even in my
conference since our French president, he is probably much
better at reasoning about figures when it comes to
economic. Although men than I myself, just because he
was the minister of the economy for many years.
And he's a professional doing that. And you would
hope that politicians are good at doing that. And
to be honest, I don't know what my colleagues
in political science who work on political elites are
finding, I hope that they are finding that they
had a decent numerical literacy, but I'm not completely
convinced.
Yeah, le let's see, let's see about that. So,
OK, so in our previous conversation, we talked a
little bit about misinformation and just to try to
perhaps establish a bridge between our two conversations here.
Uh WHEN it comes to sharing partisan news on
social media specifically. So you mean
you mean making partisan news of, of, of, of
news finds us sorry, like you mean like sharing,
sharing you selectively in a way that is partisan?
Yes, exactly. Exactly. So do do strong moral convictions
also play a role there. And if so what
are the consequences?
Um Yes, they do. They absolutely do. So we
have, we have that uh that paper recently published
in, in Pnes Nexus with um my friends Sasha
Altai and, and Brain Street Clan again, in which
we essentially show using you know, relatively simple online
experiments that the more people that, that first of
all people are, are, are disposed to engage in
what we call my side sharing or partisan sharing.
They report higher willingness to share, you know, news
items either true or false that fit the ideology.
You know, there are congruent to their side that
for instance, portray, you know, um a social threat
that they are likely to believe in. Let's say
I'm a democrat, I'm gonna want to pass along
and I'm gonna be more likely to pass along
the news that a piece of news that says
that, I don't know, there's a big problem but
like uh 3d printing of guns because it's gonna
cause, you know, the spread of, of, of, of,
of like homemade guns in the US or whatnot.
So people tend to share news that are con
to their side uh plausible threats. Um Statistical facts
that they think are true. You know, for instance,
um you should take a bunch of like a
liberal participants. They are fairly likely to pass along.
Uh A news item that says that this, for
instance, you know, five or 10% gender pay gap
between men and women in the US, which is
roughly true, right? But they're also pretty likely to
want to share um a piece of fake news
that will say that there's a 60% pay gap
between men and women, which is false, which is
vastly exaggerated. Right. So, yeah, news items, claims, uh
rumors, true or false when they fit people's uh
prior expectations and moral commitments, you know, uh political
convictions, um, activist motivations or whatnot uh will tend
to be passed along more in real life and
social media. The, the, the studies that are included
in the paper that I'm talking about are only
on social media, but we also know that that's
the case in, in real life. Um So, yeah,
people have the tendency that 10 is amplified by
uh the degree to which demoralize or that they
deem you know, certain issue to be of like
political priority for them. So whether, you know, they
see a political issue, gun control abortion or, or
the, or the ban on abortion, for instance, for,
for conservatives as being like a core value for
their moral identity, for instance, or are being central
to their moral identity when people, you know, rate.
Um I mean, report that they highly more or
less an issue that amplifies identity to share uh
new selectively. Uh And we also find unsurprisingly that
people who are more extreme on an issue, even
when they don't moralize, it are more likely to
uh to share news related to that issue in
ways that are, that are partisan. So what does
that mean? Um It can mean a mix of
several things. Um The spontaneous interpretation would simply be
to say that, you know, the more people care
about an issue. They want, people want to tackle
a social problem. They want to, with the more
they want to advance or cause the, the more
they are to behave like little activists, like little,
you know, militant members of a tribe. And they
want to pass along, you know, um claims information
that they think will mobilize other people to take
action or that potentially can also um they, they
can also pass along those militant claims because they
expect that they will therefore be able to signal,
you know, a group memberships. I think both motivations
are taking place. I think both mechanisms uh are
driving part sharing to some extent. Um But we
admit that it's also unclear whether um people are
not also simply sharing uh you know, news items
in partition ways because they think that the message
that the, that the claim and caption, it is
more plausible. So there's a sort of like there's
a sort of like, you know, um it's hard
to tell to what extent partisan safety sharing is
carried forward by stronger prior beliefs or strong convictions
that the claim is true versus more motivated thinking
or more political or, or more motivations that, that,
that sort of like motivate people to act in
somewhat activist ways by signaling allegiances and by trying
to influence the the belief of others about those,
those um those social topics potentially to, to mobilize
them or to prompt them to act, that's a
little unclear. Uh And in that paper, we're not
in a position to, to tell what is the
relative contribution of the two mechanisms. And there's a
big debate right now in political behavior, political psychology,
political science about the extent to which um you
know, differences between partisans in behavior, in news consumption,
in judgments of accuracy of a given claim in
decisions to share news, et cetera. To what extent
those differences between partisans between political subgroups are explained
by, you know, political motivated thinking, instrumental, instrumental motives
as opposed to more, uh you know, accuracy oriented,
just differences in part of beliefs. Uh It's a
big, it's a big debate right now. I can
only recommend your uh your viewers to check out
the work of Ben Tappin, which has done a
lot of good work with the Golden Penny Cook
and David ran about that. But they try to,
to argue that much, many instances of what seem
to be partisan motivated thinking might actually boil down
to different in priors. I think, I think the
argument that they make is pretty convincing. I still
think that motivated thinking is real. I still think
that it's very real. Um But it's clearly the
case that a lot in a lot of like
survey contexts, a lot of like social science context,
what might be taken at face value as evidence
of motivated thinking might actually boil down to just
partisan disagreements in what is true in the world
and what is plausible piece of information. You know.
Now I think you asked me, you, you, you
asked me about the consequences of moralizing the topic
and, and the, the impact of uh of that
on, on, on, on, on partisan sharing of, of
news items. So, yeah, as I said, it amplifies
your, your propensity to, to effectively share news that
fit your ideology. But in the paper, we, we
don't just describe uh we don't just register that
fact. We also try to um test to what
extent it is robust and to what extent it
can be kind of like influenced or mitigated by
interventions. And so when we manipulated the the perceived
um audience of the sharing, is it the group?
Is it the art group didn't seem to have
much of an effect? But I can come back
to that because we have another paper in which
the my machine works. Uh We in the same
paper with ASHA Alai and, and BR Mle, we
also manipulated whether the people are imagining to share
news from a anonymous personal account, didn't have any
effect on the the patterns of sharing, still engaging
in public but sharing. And towards the end of
the paper, we also tested an intervention which in
which we told participants that essentially they have a
confirmation bias and that, that may potentially bias, you
know, their new sharing decisions. And the last experiment
in which we tell them that they also have
a sharing bias that they have a propensity to
share more stuff that align with their, with their
ideology that tells them what they want to hear.
And neither of those, uh, two last interventions really
had much of an effect. I think they tended
to reduce a little bit overall showing but small
effect, very small effect. It didn't, uh, reduce people's
propensity to share news selectively. It didn't make people
more likely to share incongruent news and less likely
to share congruent news. Ok. So what it would,
what all that suggests, I think is that selective
sharing and its amplification by moralization and actually extremity
is very robust. It's something that is deeply entrenched
in people's cognitive uh dispositions and that makes sense
if um it's underpinned by more motivations, we know
that more motivations are trade off insensitive, right? If
you really care about defending abortion, if you are,
you know, a, a convinced conservative, why would you,
why would you swayed in your moral in your
political fight by a small, you know, intervention, you
know, sort of experiments, of course, that's unlikely to
have much of an effect because, you know, we
are touching upon deeply entrenched, um you know, identity
relevant moral convictions. And if, and to the extent
that the part is sharing is driven by sincere
convictions about, you know, there being a threat associated
to a given issue or um beliefs about the
fact that the art group is really evil and
really stupid. Well, here again, it's not a small
intervention in a sort of experiment that is gonna
sway that belief that you have acquired over the
years, over, over, you know, many repeated trials of
like consuming partisan media and conversations with people, etcetera,
etcetera. So in general, it's very hard to change
uh people's news diets, uh intuitive reactions to political
messages simply because they have a long biographical history
and they are deeply entrenched either in people's expectations
about the world or their political commitments and that's
hard to modify and surprisingly.
Mhm. So it's, it seems to me that it's
difficult, at least as far as we know to
curb this tendency that most people have to share
strongly partisan news, including sometimes fake news. Right. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Um IT is generally difficult. Um SOME
people like uh Sasha Altai and Hugo Messi would
even argue that, you know, should we be spending
that much uh of our work and our, you
know, money on trying to come up with like
interventions and get misinformation. Um The spread of misinformation
is to begin with not that big of a
problem. At least in the West, people don't consume
that much uh fake news. You know, most of
the fake news are shared by a tiny little
majority of Twitter users and Facebook and Facebook users
does the work for instance of uh you know,
um Matias Osmundsen and Michael Ben Pearson and others,
you know, who have a American Political Science review
that shows that most of the spreaders of part
fake news are actually less than 1% of the
Twitter sample that they could get access to. And
that, that less than 1% is showing 90% of
the fake news or something like that. So it's
on the whole, in addition to the fact that
few fake news are being shared in the, in
the sample. Ok. So there's few, there's little circulation
of misinformation overall, you know, a lot of studies
and that that's what they find. And a very
small minority of like pretty cynical activists seem to
be doing the heavy lifting of sharing that information.
So maybe we're exaggerating the seriousness of misinformation. It
doesn't mean that it's not a problem at all.
It is for sure a problem. It is a
problem that, for instance, you know, people increasingly uh
in some areas of the world are dispersed full
of vaccines. It is a problem that the Russians
are spreading, you know, anti-french propaganda uh in Africa
and taking advantage of that, of those misinformation campaigns
to send their Wagner soldiers and to increase their
influence in West Africa. That's of course a problem.
But as far as like the circulation of misinformation
on social media about politics in the West is
concerned is possible that we're exaggerating a little bit.
Uh THE seriousness of the problem. And so what,
what people like Sasha Alta and Yuma would say,
and I'm, and I'm sure they're, they're right if
they thought about it more than I have, what
we should instead say is to try to focus
our efforts and our time and our money on
making people care more about trusting uh reliable sources.
OK. Like increasing people's trust in uh the Washington
Post, the New York Times, Le Monde le Figaro,
uh El Pais and whatnot. OK. So the priority
should not be in trying to fight misinformation. It's
hard. It may, it may even backfire by reinforcing
conspiracy theories and whatnot. The priority should be to
try to restore a little bit trust in institutions
and trust in journalism. And if we, and if
we manage to increase a little bit people's trust
in a legitimate legacy news media, if we manage
to make them consume a bit more reliable information,
we would diminish the amount of false beliefs and
misinformation in society much more than we would if
we manage to make people a bit more distrustful
of uh you know, fake news sources and whatnot.
At least that's the argument that they defend. So
I don't know if it answers a bit what
you were saying, but that's my uh interpretation of
uh I mean, what would be said, what would
have to be said here?
Mhm. Yeah. And actually I have uh seal t
on the show two or three years ago and
when it comes to the seriousness of the sharing
of fake news online in social media, particularly, uh
if I remember correctly said basically the same you
said there. And I, I think that uh you
were focusing mostly on people who share fake news
there. But uh it also applies to people who
actually produce fake news and put, put it into
circulation on the internet. It's just a tiny, tiny,
tiny minority of people doing that. Right.
Yeah, I imagine so. I haven't, I haven't worked
on like, you know, the, the famous producers, like
the websites who, uh, you know, who output fake
news online, of course, they're pursuing, you know, clicks
and, and attention and revenue when they're here for
the, for the money, for the most part, they
might also have, you know, disruptive motivations, like more
political motivations to undermine trust in the establishment or
in journalism or in, you know, the current politicians
or whatnot. Um, I, I don't know, I don't
know what I mean here again, I think, you
know, the, the, the, the, the, the proportion of
information producers who are intentionally cynical, intentionally spreading misinformation
is extremely small. Uh Of course, it's absolutely problematic
that they exist and there should be, you know,
uh probably penal sanctions against them and, you know,
the, the government should crack down on them at
Zara, but it's easy to overestimate the gravity of
the issue simply because, you know, um the mind
is extremely uh uh you know, hyper sensitive to,
to threat in general. So that's true of like
citizens. That's true of journalists, that's true of politicians
or researchers. So any information that somehow contributes to
saying that there is something that is not working
well in society will be a bit more, you
know, believed a bit more uh culturally successful uh
holding constant other factors. Of course, I'm not saying
that you can make people believe, you know, anything
and everything, people aren't completely good. But if the
threat seems plausible and if it seems relevant, uh
it's gonna spread far and wide. And so there's
a tendency for the broad public and, and, and,
and, and sentence themselves to, to think that it,
to think that the, the problem of misinformation is
very broad is very big and they indicate can
potentially also have, you know, a career incentives, publication
incentives to also further exa exaggerate the threat. So
I think we have to keep that in mind.
Yeah, like the mind is super attentive to threat,
we easily exaggerate things. It's relevant, right? Makes us
sound interesting in the conversation and it creates opportunities
for publication for talks for uh you know, a
commission that the parliament or what not. And um
and that will, that will make sense. I mean,
I'm not necessarily, you know, throwing stones at people
who participate in that I have perhaps participated in
that kind of like more panic about misinformation myself
intentionally or not. But we should keep in mind
that. Yeah, the, the, the problem is probably not
as serious as the climate changes or the, the
war in uh in Israel is.
Mhm. So, in a related topic, uh in our
previous conversation, we've also talked a little bit about
conspiracy theories. And in this time, I would like
to ask you about specifically when it comes to
political conspiracy theories and other kinds of rebased narratives.
Are there social functions to holding and disseminating them?
Yeah, presumably at least that's what we argue with
uh Mika Pearson and, and others, but Mikel Bang,
in particular, in, in at least a couple of
pieces that we have written together. Um So again,
the mind is very, is very susceptible to threatening
information, right? Uh We are a loss of earth.
It makes sense to, you know, um get ourselves
ready for, for threatening a threat. So it's obviously
adaptive to overreact to information that there may be
a social threat um in particular social threats that,
you know, take a group based form, right? Because
uh we humans evolved in an essential environment in
which presumably there was a fair amount of group
competition and group conflict. Um And so it's, it's
adaptive to overreact to be kind of like on
the on the lookout for potential or coordinate social
threats directed against us, directed against our in group
are keen and Sarah and once people have that
predisposition to find, you know, threat based narratives, appealing
like conspiracy theories, um potentially also some popular forms
of like uh Marxism, anti racist discourse, anti-communist discourse,
et cetera, much of ideologies, threat based narratives, right?
I mean, whether you're trying to, you know, um
motivate people to um take action against communism or
whether you're trying to motivate your population to take
actions against the capitalist imperialism and to endorse communism
In all those cases, you're going to try to
spin threat based narratives and to, you know, uh
diffuse them in society through the journals of propaganda
through the channels of general education, through the, the
radio, et cetera. So threat based narratives are absolutely
central in politics and in, in, in, in ideological
phenomena. And so once you have that ubiquitous with
based narratives uh that, you know, uh the mind
responds to and finds intuitive attention grabbing and uh
well pay attention to it becomes possible to use
them instrumentally strategically to influence how people think of
yourself and, and, and, and, and act. So if
I, if I had a good, you know, threat
based narrative that can get my group to team
up together and to attack or defend against an
enemy group, if I can somehow convince that, you
know, there's a dangerous art group right there in
the neighboring um behind the neighboring hill or in
the neighboring nation that is poi poised to attack
us and who wants to exterminate us. I will
easily be able to reap the benefits of like
mobilizing my group against that art group. OK. So
they are mobilizing benefits in, in using instrumentally threads
narratives. And we suspect that at least sometimes that's
how PC theories are being used. Uh People use
them to kind of like recruit um new individuals
to join a political fight, a political cause that
they care about. For instance, you know, anti-establishment uh
uh narrative or, or some kind of like a
more racist narrative against uh you know, the neighboring
tribe that you, that you may be living close
to in like the Middle East or in Africa
or whatnot. And so, and so, yeah, it becomes
possible to, to kind of like instrumentally agitate a
sense of threat in other people to mobilize them
to side with you and to take action with
you on your side and to potentially uh yeah,
organize collectively to, to, to thwart a potential threat.
Um And, and there's at least another potential um
social use that can be made of uh of
this narrative that is also very instrumental that it
is also a little exploitative, which is a signaling,
of course, you know, by, by saying how much
you hate an art group, by saying how much
you think that the art group is uh dangerous,
uh you know, uh conspiring against you with Zara.
Zara, you can express a sense of loyalty to
your own group, you can, you can by, by
see who you hated society, you're potentially sort of
like, you know, distinguishing yourself from a food that
in group and also potentially neutral audiences who don't
care about it and you're singling you, you're signing.
So you're expressing who you're sending with. And that
can be uh that can be useful to um
that can be useful to uh to, to express
to potential allies to potential recruits, you know, that
you're standing with them, that you care about the
interests itself. Um As you mentioned, one important thing
about the mobilization argument, which is that this, there's
kind of a debate in the country, sciences, of
culture and political science and what not about the
extent to which those um threat based narratives really
persuade people or really motivate people to act so
on, on a sort of like optimistic accounts when
you spread, you know, threat based rumor or conspiracy
theory that seems to be believable or, you know,
a cons spiritual narrative or like a sort of
like um ethnic rumor about the fact that, you
know, the neighboring Tutsi are gonna want to massacre
all your uh um Hutu fellows or whatnot under
an optimistic argument, uh an optimistic view of the
argument, those claims will persuade and will really get
people to act because they're afraid of threat, which
we really have motivational impact. I think sometimes it's
the case. Um BUT people like Michael B, Peterson
and maybe also Hugo Mercier have argued and I'm
pretty convinced by that, by that argument that very
often people are not so much convinced, you know,
prompted to act and to take arms against the
threat as they are more using the information as
a way of like signaling that they are willing
to attack, that they're ready to attack already. And
they're using the propaganda, the threat based rumor, the
narrative as a way of like saying, hey, I'm
one of those guys who hate the other group.
I'm willing to take action. And I'm saying that
to you in order to signal that I'm ready
to coordinate with you in a potential collective action
that we might want to take against the other
group. OK. So under a sort of like strong
form of the claim, the negative information really persuades
people to act under, under a broader exception of
the, of the argument or, or the thesis, it
doesn't really prompt people to act, but it helps
people who are already motivated to act for other
reasons, to organize collectivity, to coordinate and to prepare
a collective action that may potentially, you know, target
the other group.
Yeah. Uh And if that second um interpretation of
it is the correct one. Could it, could it
be that in this case uh conspiracy, a political
conspiracy theory or any other sort of threat based
narrative could function more as a sort of justification
to act than really uh as motivating people to
act upon it.
Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Um It could, it could serve,
it could allow individuals to rationalize an already existing
motivation to, you know, organize collective action and to
attack or to defend against the art group. Um
Stereotypes, you know, are not necessarily always super, super
believable. Uh Conspiracy theories are not always super super
believable, but just the fact that they are superficially
plausible or that they um can be at least,
you know, superficially endorsed by your allies may suffice
for them to function as like postdoc rationalizations of
an already existing disposition to hate the art group
and to want to attack against the other group.
Yes. Yes. And, and by, by, by, by, by,
by expressing endorsement of the conspiracy theory or the,
the, the ethnic rumor or whatnot, but just saying
that you believe it or by disseminating it on
yourself, you also signal that you're one of those
individuals who want to act. So there's also a
signaling value, at least it contributes to co-ordination of
collective action. So it signals a membership, it gets
you closer to a coordinate action that is meaningful
in terms of collective action that may be hostile
to the art group. And you're right, it can
also uh rationalize under under the existing motivation to,
to take action.
Uh And uh I mean, just before we move
to, we move to another topic, uh you mentioned
there, the fact that it's still debatable to what
extent conspiracy theories might have actual behavioral effects. I
mean, in terms of mobilizing people to do something
uh that also apply. I mean, this is an
ongoing debate also that applies to things like the
spread of misinformation, political ads during campaigns, online, et
cetera. Right? I mean, we're still not sure to
what extent stuff like that, particularly on social media
and the internet more generally really translating to actual
offline behavior. Right.
Yeah, and, and offline behavior as well. Um I
mean, here I can be, I can be, again,
the echo of, you know, the work of Hugo
me here for a second because I think it's
very uh it's very convincing even if I sometimes
think that Hugo is going a tad too far
and his optimism about human rationality. But I think
the, the general arguments are pretty, pretty strong, pretty
valid. People are not easily gullible, they are not
easily um fooled, they have intuitive capacities to gauge
the coherence and consistency of new information with what
they already believe. And they're pretty good at gauging
whether sources of information and messages have their interests
at heart or are trying to deceive them and
whatnot. So that's what he calls, you know, epistemic
vigilance or in a in a more novel formulation,
open open visions. So I think that's very true.
Of course, um you won't easily um you know,
make Germans become anti Semitic if there's not an
already pretty strong pre-existing disposition for anti-semitism in German
culture that is, you know, plunging in roots um,
in, you know, several centuries of, of, of, uh
Catholic uh and, and partisan history, you won't easily
get people to buy products that they absolutely don't
need. You won't create helo um, new desires. Uh
That's, I think actually, by the way, if you,
if you allow me to, um hit a little
bit on the standard of social scientists who are
not cognitive and who are not evolutionary, I think
that's often like a sort of like a misconception
that a lot of people in traditional sociology or
whatnot may have is that they think that capitalism
advertisement propaganda, um it's have the capacity to generate
non practicing desires. I think that there, that's, that's
generally misconception, human nature is about the same for
everybody and it's pretty deeply structured by a transaction
pressures. You won't easily persuade people to desire commodities
or activities that they are not evolution be predisposed
to like. Right. So in general, what advertisement does
is that it will exploit and obey the existing
predisposition for, I don't know, um junk food, you
know, fat stuff, sugary stuff. It will explode to
pre uh predi predisposition to, you know, want to
have sex and to um want to see, you
know, attractive sexual partners, et Zara and he's going
to present products or services that tap those pre-existing
desires. Uh And, and if it manages to sell
more new services, new goods. It's because it's making
products that type, that tap those already existing desires,
more salient, more visible it for them, but it's
not creating desires from nothing. Ethnic yellow at all,
I think. Mhm. Uh, YEAH. I don't know if
it's, if it's answering your, your question in any
way.
No, no. Maybe, maybe
a little, if you, maybe a little element that
I think I should add about like the, the
the potency of like propaganda and, and, and rumors
and you know, like kind of like discourses that
aim to persuade and to mobilize people. Um An
argument that Hugo would make in this case and
that I'm increasingly convinced by is that um very
often when people say that the endorsement theories or
that they endorse, you know, ideologies like Marxism or
like a, a pretty radical ideology very often what
is likely to be happening in their heads is
that people claim to be endorsing the, the, the
statement of the belief they ascend to it. They
say that they believe it, but in fact, deep
down in their and conscious other systems are, are
like uh not really, you know, like they're not
really taking the information super seriously to the extent
of motivating costly action, costly action, big efforts on
the part of the individual. So very often people
will say that they endorse fashionable beliefs because they
allow them to, you know, seem informed, to seem
like they care about certain values that other people
care about. Um, THEY'RE gonna endorse them to, um,
to seem like, yeah, trustworthy, competent to seem like
they care about politics, etcetera. But in fact, they
very rarely will deviate from their, you know, personal
comfort or like, you know, everyday ways of doing
things and, you know, private little self interest. Um,
ON the basis of those belies very often, the,
the, the epistemic visions mechanisms are, it's not that
they are like turning down the information on the
endorsement of the narrative, but it's more like they
are keeping it in a sort of like isolated
co format which, you know, me be would call
reflective without really trying to connect them with like
costly actions that would potentially entail sacrifices for the
individuals. And uh and also big efforts in terms
of like mobilizing others and really, you know, like
spending money and time on like uh political calls
that people claim to care about. But in fact,
don't really do much to it in general. And,
and by the way, I'm completely, I'm completely guilty
of the same problem myself. OK? Like I'm giving
a bit of money every month to uh to
give well, and I'm trying to do a few,
like not so costly altruistic stuff. Uh But I
really take costly action in favor of more values
that, that, that I claim that I claim to
care about. Uh I claim to care about the
environment, but I'm still playing way too much and
still eating a bit, a bit too much chicken.
And so I'm, I'm completely guilty of the same
mechanism that I'm describing here. Uh
But so I, if that's true, then in this
particular case, uh people manifesting certain specific beliefs would,
would serve mainly a social signaling function, right? In
terms of signaling, their, I guess, group affiliations,
yeah, signaling. Um So I think, you know, what's
happening very often is that we have mechanisms in
the mind that are, that evolve for tax benefits
that were essentially relevant, you know, getting your coalition
to co-operate together to solve a problem or throw
out an enemy to signal your trustworthiness to be
kept and admitted as a group as a good
group member and whatnot and those motivations. So those
many divisions would have expressed themselves with like intensity
in the past when there was like, like a
lot of fitness interdependence. And when there was like
a lot of like external threat on the group
or whatnot, there are people would have, you know,
spent a lot of energy to um get their
group to team up together, or they would have
spent a lot of energy to signal their devotion
to the group by incurring pretty costly sacrifices to
deserve their place in the group at Zara because
back at the time, the environment was very threatening.
But nowadays, typically, most of us would live in
you know, relatively peaceful western societies in which there
is no war, there is no famine, there are
no uh natural catastrophes and whatnot. And so we
are not in dire need to mobilize other people
in collective action or we do, we are not
as much in dire need to signal group memberships
as, as we, as we used to potentially. And
so we're gonna, we're gonna still have those mechanisms
opening in our, in the background of our heads.
We're still gonna be doing a little bit of,
of like political and, and more signaling but not
with the same intensity, not at the price of
like as costly actions as maybe we would have
in intra context in, in context of like group
conflict or in or with as much intensity as
we would in like contemporary context that are prone
to war or where, you know, people are a
bit more in danger. So I would say that
the motivations are there uh But they are only
operating in a sort of like weak diminished form
in people's heads. But still, it's enough that they're
operating in a sort of like, you know, uh
minimal mode for the, for the belief that people,
for people to endorse beliefs and to disseminate claims
in ways that, you know, seem to, yeah, that,
that seem that still seem to fulfill signaling functions
and, and potentially uh mobilization functions.
So changing topics, you have a paper where you
explore the ways by which strongly motivate people that
are strongly morally motivated or committed to gender equality
in this specific case process and understand evidence regarding
gender bias hiring processes. So, uh and the and
of course, there are benefits to being committed to
gender equality in this specific case. But in the
paper, you also talk about potential costs. Could you
explain what's going on here?
Yeah, it's all very simple. So we have that
uh we have that pre print paper that uh
got rejected from many places, but I hope it
will one day be accepted by a decent social
psychology journal uh with um co authors um uh
Hu Ling Xiao, who's a, who's a Chinese colleague
and Andre Mle, my former PH advisor in which
we look at like how people consume um simplified
scientific accounts, uh simplified, you know, research summaries about
the topic of gender bias in hiring in organizations
and doctor in stem. And we look at how
the degree of like feminism, if you will the
de the degree to which they moralize gender equality
influences those evaluations, the degree to which they think
those scientific uh reports are credible, the methods are
rigorous, you know, the the findings are convincing sr
itself. And so there's, there's a, there's a, there's
a PNS paper that came out in 2015, I
think by Henry at a that showed that essentially
when people were presented with uh scientific demonstrations using,
you know, randomized control trials or like rigorous experimental
methods. When people were exposed to those uh proofs
that um having processes in academia favor uh men
over women with equal credentials, they found that men
were less receptive to that uh type of scientific
result that women were more likely to believe them
and to want to take action against, against those
uh against those findings. OK. So they found that
there was some kind of like a sex difference
in how receptive or how um how truthful people
were at that demonstration. And so here, what we
tried to do was to was to see first
is that sex effect, video, sex effect or is
it more like an moral ideology effect that is
associated or co varying with the sex difference? Is
it possible that the sex difference is in fact
reducible to differences in moral commitments in the degree
to which people care about sex equality um in
our, in our, you know, uh population of participants.
And yes, it seems to be the, it seems
to be the case when we control for more
commitment very often the sex effect disappears. And when
we add more commitment as a covariance of people,
the variations of the degree to which they trust
the science they think is believable. Um We find
that the more people care about more equality, the
more they will trust, the more they will deem
plausible uh convincing those scientific reports that demonstrate experimentally
that uh women are being discriminated against in having
processes in academia. So that's, that's a bright side.
Ok. So we, we, we, we expand already existing
study. We showed that what seemed to be a
sex effect is actually maybe more like a moral
ideology effect. And we find that good news, people
who care more about equality will uh welcome more
with more receptivity, those rigorous demonstrations that we may
not be discriminated against. However, on the flip side,
we also find that people who are more uh
more committed to equality, uh see as more persuading,
as more persuasive, sorry. Um MORE bogus demonstrations or
conclusions that there is gender bias in having taking
place. So here, what we did is that we
substituted the rigorous uh experimental demonstration of gender bias
in hiring with a more observational and fishy study
that essentially looks at the pre hiring um proportion
of men and women in stem and the post
hiring proportions. And that finds that in fact, the
post hiring proportions of women is greater than the
pre hiring proportions. So clearly, there's no gender bias
in having against women. And and, and we, and
we visualize that graphically with like pretty clear about
shots and like there's no ambiguity about the fact
that women are really favored in having process. And
yet the research Army concludes that the fact that
women on the whole, even after hiring are still
a minority because they, they are a minority before
and after hiring, the fact that women are a
minority in science in the scientific labs is a
rigorous demonstration of the fact that, you know, there's
gender bias in hiring. So that's a fac conclusion
because people infer from the fact that women are
less generous, the notion that there should be inevitably
uh you know, gender-based in having against them, even
when the presented data is clearly showing that women
all things equal, actually favored in the recruiting recruitment
process. OK. And so here we find that people
um generally tend to do not process the contribution
between the result and the conclusion and the higher
and more commitment to the equality, the more people
are likely to rate that bogus scientific conclusion as
being, you know, convincing. OK. So overall, in summary,
if you care, it seems that if you care
more about gender equality, if you're more of a
feminist, you will. And that's a and that's a
good thing rate more positively believe more rigorous demonstration
of their being uh gender bias against women. But
you will also be more receptive and more believing
of bogus demonstrations that only rely on observational evidence
and that are even, you know, showing results that
are contradictory with the conclusion. So this of course,
does not, you know, amount to uh saying that
we should stop being uh caring about gender equality.
We should, of course uh uh keep caring about
that sort of like moral and political targets, a
very important one. But the lesson that we are
trying to teach here and we're not the first
ones to be making that argument is that um
when you are very committed to a cause, it
can potentially blend you a little bit, you know,
to the details of a reasoning, it can make
you a bit more susceptible to confirmation bias or
um or belief bias in the sense that if
you really endorse a conclusion, if you think that
the conclusion is true, if you think that the
conclusion is more desirable, it makes you a bit
more likely to neglect the inferential steps or the
reasoning that back it up and that lead to
it. And that's what we're trying to show essentially,
you know, morality binds and blinds. As Jonathan, he
would say it, it can make people a bit
more irrational uh at the margins, even even if
you know, the aggregate social effects are on average
positive, at least sometimes it's gonna bias people's reasoning
and we want to show that.
Mhm. So when it comes to these ideological commitments
that some people have, uh you've also been working
on ideological orthodoxy and specifically on the repression of
free speech. So what do we know about what
might motivate and what might be the goals that
a strong political activists try to pursue when repressing
free speech?
OK. So here you're referring to my work with
uh Mika Van Heeren um recent work, you know,
just published or still in the pipes at Sara.
So not much is is out yet. We have
um we have a we have a commentary article
on, on David Pino and our uh the alliance
theory of ideology that, that our commentary is called
speech prepress and outrage from orthodox activists as attempts
at fascinating mobilizations and getting service among allies. I'm
sorry, the title is a little long but you
know, your, your viewers are welcome to check it
out. And we have also like a longer piece
in preparation that is currently called the Ky Foundations
of Orthodoxy in which we try to expand a
bit those arguments in a somewhat more detailed form.
So, yeah, Michael and I have taken the phenomenon
of like political dogmatism and speech repression as our
sort of like object of inquiry. Recently, we've become
interested in that um for various reasons. Uh One
because we think that, you know, there's a bit
too much repression of speech in the world uh
nowadays still obviously also because um we think that
there's a bit too much of it in uh
in, in the west, in, in the US, in
particular, there's a somewhat, you know, concerning phenomenon of
cancel culture that is threatening uh universities and intellectual
professions that we think is pretty problematic. And of
course, because, you know, speech is still massively repressed
in authoritarian countries uh the world over and we,
and we told, we told ourselves that, well, it
seems like there's not really a, a mature cognitive
and evolutionary theory of like, why people are orthodox
or we press free speech in ideological movements, you
know, be they moral movements, religious movements, political movements
and whatnot. And so we, we told ourselves, well,
let's try to develop a theory of like why
there is, you know, the anti-communist witch hunt in
the fifties. Why is there, uh you know, the
repression and the surveillance of political dissent in China
right now? Why did the Catholic church, you know,
persecute the heretics in the middle ages and why
is there a cancel culture in the US right
now? Both on the left and on the right.
So that's a bit explanatory target if I, if
I may say and so what we say is
essentially pretty similar to, you know, what we've been
saying about the conspiracy theories and what, you know,
people like cosine and tube and, and, and other
authors have been saying about, you know, um more
beliefs and political beliefs, essentially, we are proposing that
people re speech for two main reasons. Uh Mobilization
goals and signaling goals. So the mobilization goal would
be fulfilled in the following way. If you care
a lot about the issue, uh you will want
to, you know, uh rally your life and to
motivate your life to, you know, create a coalition,
create, create a sort of like group uh behind
yourself with yourself to tackle the threat, right? You
might want to vanquish uh racism in the US.
For instance, you might want to, um, you know,
um thwart the threat of communist infiltration in the
US in the 19 fifties if you're like a,
like a ma artist or what not. And so
there's a sort of like intrinsic desire or need
to organize collective action if you want to advance
a cult or if you want to defeat an
enemy, be it also like an intellectual enemy, it
doesn't have to be a human out group. It
can be like dangerous ideas that you think are
exerting, you know, a corruptive influence on your society
or whatnot. And so in those conditions, that goal
of mobilization becomes to try to influence people's beliefs
so that they believe that uh the mobilization is,
is justified, is necessary. And typically, one way of
doing that is to tell people that there's a
threat because if there's a threat, you know, it's
gonna activate our evolved sense of like threat, avoidance.
It's very powerful from a motivational perspective. And so
often you can motivate people to gang together behind
you to organize for your side if you can
convince them that they are facing a threat. And
in that context, what we're saying is that people
activists, political leaders, ideological entrepreneurs, et cetera, et cetera,
they will try to, they will tend to try
to regulate free speech and to maybe repress free
speech when they think that the speech in question
is potentially demobilizing when, when they think that potentially
the information is contrarian or is kind of like
calling into question the legitimacy of the fight or
it contributes to nuance or procession of the threat
or contributes to uh say that the threat is
not that bad after all or what not, you
know what I mean? So like uh if I
take the example of, you know, the the canceling
of controversial speakers on us campuses uh recently by
the left, but also by the right, if you're
a staunch anti racist, you may want to deplatform
or to cancel the invitation or to stop um
the, the, the talk from taking place of a
biologist who's doing research on, let's say the link
between genetics and, and, and personality or someone who's
investigating potential, you know, psychological differences or IQ differences
between populations and whatnot because rightfully or wrongfully, I
don't know, it's, it's an open question. You might
think that those pieces of information in, if it's
sif research, those pieces of information may contribute to
normalize, to justify uh racism, not necessarily directly but
even indirectly as you know, making like uh maybe
a biological conception of human nature a bit more
popular or a bit more plausible and whatnot. So
you might, you might be motivated to be press
speech that you think is contrarian or susceptible to
undermine uh the third need for the necessity of
the mobilization against racism. And in particular, you will
try to repress speech that you think is undermining
people's perception of threat, right? For instance, you know,
research also that may downplay the notion that there
is a link between, you know, um the race
of the defendant and police violence, for instance, will
typically be seen as being contrarian as being dangerous
by anti racist activists because they fear that its
dissemination in society may influence people's prior beliefs towards
them. Believing that the, the the the problem of
racism is not that bad or that, you know,
it's it's exaggerated or whatnot and that may have
demobilizing effects and the same like on the right
people may want to repress free speech of um
the free expression of, for instance, you know, um
critical race theory or, you know, uh the notion
that, you know, gender roles are at least partly
socially constructed because they feel like dissemination of those
contracting messages may kind of like diminish or undermine
the the enthusiasm that people have for traditional Christian
values, et cetera. And they see that as a
threat. Ok. So one core function we think of
speech repression and speech regulation is you try to
control people's beliefs by intervening on information flows so
that people stay motivated for causes that you think
will bring about shared benefits in particular against, you
know, social threats. And of course, once there are
those efforts to mobilize allies for causes and against
enemies that creates individual incentives for people to signal
devotion to certain causes to those causes and to
the group. So once people care vastly about anti-racism,
once people have a moral panic about communist influence
in the US, in the, in the fifties, once
conservative America is going through a more panic about
critical race theory being taught at university or at
high school that creates individual opportunities for repetition and
enhancement. Uh It creates incentives for individuals to seem
like they're gonna be um very tough with uh
you know, uh control on ideas with like ideas
that they are in group, dislike as a way
of showing their degree of commitment for those ideas.
Um SORRY for the group. Uh AND, and, and
for the causes that they are trying to advance,
like, if I'm, let's say a po position in
19 fifties like Maar and there it is and
is a sort of like more panic against uh
about the influence of communism in American culture and
institutions. Well, I may see it as an opportunity
to try to erect, to emerge myself as a
tough politician, as a reliable politician who will defend,
you know, the traditional values of corporate liberal America
against the threat of communism. And so he quits
um by repressing speech um of people who are
suspected of Soviet sympathies. Someone like Mac mccalley can
emerge as someone who's committed to protect regional America
against the threat. And so, yeah, you, you, you
know, you appear tough against the contractions, you appear
tough against the enemies against people who disagree with
you. And that can potentially allow you to score
reputational points. Ok. So, uh,
uh, yeah, II, I have one more question or
topic to explore about political activists but, uh, still
on the topic of repressing free speech. I mean,
I've asked you a similar kind of question when
earlier we talked about uh spreading uh fake news
and all of that and uh how basically uh
people care more about or a apparently care more
about the values and symbols driving political decisions than
uh the concrete effects they have on society. Uh
I mean, in this particular case, are you also
interested in trying to understand perhaps if there would
be any ways we could try to curb the
repression of free speech or is that not something
that you are really studying?
Uh I mean, I'm obviously interested in that question
because, you know, the, the, the very fact that,
that I think that there's a need for a
g theory of free speech. Um Is it still
a reflection of the fact that I think that,
you know, the repression of free speech is at
least sometimes bad even if sometimes it's also desirable.
Um I think it's a good thing that for
instance, in Europe, we're trying to, you know, fight
uh neo Nazi propaganda by making it illegal to
have a swat seekers and uh and to, and
to sing a neo Nazi chants in the streets.
Um So there are cases where, I mean, I'm
not, I'm not, I'm not a free speech. Absolutely
alone. Even if I'm very pro free speech, what
can we do to reinforce or to strengthen free
speech? Um I don't know, Ricardo, I don't really
know. I haven't really studied that, uh that question
yet. Um I guess, I guess, I guess decreasing
the level of like polarization of society and trying
to make our national societies a little less conflictual
will help because um as we argue in our
work with Michael, um it seems pretty clear that
motivations, we press free speech co vary and are
sort of like upregulated, increased by perceptions of society,
be conflict ridden, you know. Mhm. When you think
that there's a dangerous out group that is threatening
your in group, which is like a, like a,
like a by definition, your perception of conflict, um
you will feel an increased need to um motivate
my group to form like a cohesive coalition or
to, you know, rally new life to, to, to
fight that threat. And um and it's to that
extent that people is to the extent that people
feel that they have benefits in mobilizing, that they
will feel that they also have benefits in repressing
speech that they think could be demobilizing, right? So
the more society is harmonious uh and the more,
you know, the different subgroups that compose society can
live their lives fairly freely. And the more uh
the, the less inequality maybe there is and the
less effective polarization there is, the less it should
be a problem. Um The, the, the less you
should have motivations from activists on, on either side
to want to be press and to police the
speech of others because yeah, again, like um motivation
to repress speech are impossible to dissociate from threat,
perceptions and motivations to, to motivate your own group
to do stuff in the world and often what
motivates. Um Yeah, that, that, that mobilization effort is
perception of threat. So I would say that, yeah,
you have to make societies a bit more peaceful
and a little less polarized as for more. So
that's of course, very difficult, right? Uh It's a
sort of like, you know, um basic fundamental uh
program for policymakers and uh you know, it involves,
you know, maybe uh changing a bit the economy,
it involves changing. Uh MAYBE the way the the
news media are functioning to make them a little
less uh to make them uh to make them
a little less polarizing, a little less partisan. It
calls for a number of reforms in many, many
different sectors of society. Uh I'm not here to
make, you know, specific policy recommendations. That's something that
I hope to maybe think a bit more about
in the future Michael, uh, might have recommendations to
that effect. I think he's giving a talk about
the future of free speech in, um, in Sweden,
uh, early December. That may be of interest to
some of your viewers. Uh, WELL, it will probably
be too late by the time your podcast is
out. But, yeah, a lot of people who are
more or less influential, are interested in how to
foor free speech. Uh, I think, um Jacob, um
what is his name? Uh Meena who wrote like
a History of Free Speech, um probably also has
pretty interesting positive recommendations about that. He's got a
very interesting book called um Free Speech or History
from Socrates to uh to I forget what that
is really good and that I can recommend your
viewers to, to check out. Uh But yeah, I'm
not, I'm not gonna venture into like specific, you
know, policy recommendations in terms of like what to
do to enforce free speech. Um I don't really
know but, but for sure that value needs to
be protected and uh and it's a cardinal value
of, of us um scientists and I assume, you
know, most regional liberals of, of, of, of, of
the West right now?
Great. So, uh would you like to tell people
just before we go the kinds of work you're
doing on right now, what kinds of topics you're
working on? And, and by the way, I didn't
mention this at the beginning in our in, in
the introduction. But in the near future, you will
also be moving to one stick to Jean Nico.
Yeah, that's it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So my, my
contract at university is reaching its end in um
end of March 24 and I have a new
job at the Envision Nico in Paris. Uh I'll
be part of the um evolution and the social
team. So evolution and social cognition and my P
I is going to be Olivia Mohan, who's a
cultural evolutionist, who's mostly been uh been doing work
on like uh the cult evolution of uh of,
of uh scriptural systems of languages. But he's interested
in cultural conservatism. Why do people want to prefer
the status quo in many cases with respect to
like, you know, preserving uh cultural traditions, preferring um
the status quo in, in between group relationships in
politics, etcetera. And so, yeah, we're going to try
to explore like what, what motivations people may have
in, in, in, in preferring the status quo. And
so I'll be back in various and working from
France, studying from uh yeah, the spring 24 and
as, as well as my current work. Well, I
would say that many of the papers that have
been talk uh that I've been talking about today
are not necessarily published yet. Uh So I'm still
like working on them a little bit. Uh And
in particular, what occupies most of my time right
now is our work with Michael Mikel Bang um
about orthodoxy and speech repression. I'm trying to write
a relatively long theory piece about, about that and
the social functions of mobilizations and, and, and signaling
that we think it fulfills. Um And so that's
my main piece of work right now. Yes.
Uh And by the way, where can people find
you on the internet?
Uh They can find me on Twitter. Uh Of
course, my handle is um a capital A uh
underscore Marie um Ma Rie underscore S CIA Marie.
I like science and also have a website that
I need to um that maybe you, you would
be able to uh to cite another video, I
guess in some websites. Um What I and you
can shoot me an email at Antoine dot Marie
dot sc I at gmail.com if they also want
to. Of course, and I'm on Facebook and you
know, find the ball through many channels.
Great. So look Antoine. Thank you so much for
coming on the show again, as I said at
the beginning of the show, it was great. Fun
to talk to you.
Thanks a lot. Have a good day. See
you. Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview.
Until the end. If you liked it, please share
it. Leave a like and hit the subscription button.
The show is brought to you by the N
Lights learning and development. Then differently check the website
at N lights.com and also please consider supporting the
show on Patreon or paypal. I would also like
to give a huge thank you to my main
patrons and Paypal supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry Muller and
Frederick Suno, Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam, Castle
Matthew Whitten Bear. No wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ
Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then the Met Robert Wine
in NAI Z Mar Nevs calling in Hobel Governor
Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferger and
H her me and Lain Jung Y and the
Samuel K Hes Mark Smith J Tom Hummel S
Friends, David Sloan Wilson, ya de ro ro Diego,
Jan Punter Romani Charlotte, Bli Nico Barba, Adam Hunt
Pavlo Stassi Nale medicine, Gary G Alman, Sam Ofri
and YPJ Barboa, Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Broner
Douglas Fry Franca Beto Lati Cortez Solis Scott Zachary
ftdw Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio, Luke Loki,
Georgio Theophano. Chris Williams and Peter Wo David Williams
Di Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Larry Dey junior, Old Ebon,
Starry Michael Bailey. Then Spur by Robert Grassy Zorn.
Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radis Mark Kemple Thomas
Dvor Luke Neeson, Chris to Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert,
Jessica, Nicky Linda Brendan Nicholas Carlson Ismael Bensley Man
George Katis, Valentine Steinman, Perros, Kate Von Goler, Alexander
Albert Liam Dan Biar Masoud Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular J
Ner Urla. Good enough Gregory Hastings David Pins of
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos Net. A special
thanks to my producers is our web, Jim Frank
Luca Toni, Tom Veg and Bernard N Cortes Dixon
Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John
Carl, Negro, Nick Ortiz and Nick Golden. And to
my executive producers, Matthew lavender, Si Adrian Bogdan Knits
and Rosie. Thank you for all.